استهداف وقصف جديد هنا في هذه المحطه التي
تم استهدافها بصواريخ من قبل طيارات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه القصف جاء على جميع
محتويات هذه المحطه كان هناك طابق ثاني
وطابق ارضي كما تشاهدون وكذلك المحطه
ذاتها اضافه الى السياره تم تدميرها نتيجه
هذا القصف العنيف في هذا المكان على شارع
صلاح الدين بالقرب من مستشفى غزه الاوروبي
على الساعه 9عه و0 اي ما فطنت الا الحجار
وال
والركام بينزل
علينا بعد ربع ساعه طلعت للاولاد سالتهم
بخير و بخير 12 نفر عندي 12 شخص انا
وعيالي وانا من اول الحرب وانا بنام في
المحطه سنا ننزل الاطفال والنسان على
كتوفنا من هناك واحد يناول واحد من ورا
لما نزلناه كليتهم بدمهم ايش ايش سووا هول
ايش سووا ايش سووا رغم هذا احنا صامدين في
ارضنا جذرين فيها وبنقول للعدو ونتنياهو
احنا حلنا في ارضنا قاعدين لو ب يجي احنا
مش طالعين من ارضنا ولا متحركين من ارضنا
ما يسلم من اله الحرب الاسرائيليه البريه
تطاله طائراته في الجو وفي المحصله تدمير
وقتل هكذا هو المشهد في قطاع غزه منذ 121
يوما اسماعيل ابو عمر قناه الجزيره خان
يونس m